(bouncing classical music)
- [Narrator] This is Gila.
He's a Gila monster.
The only species of lizard
native to the United States
that is venomous.
But, don't worry, these laggard
lizards aren't exactly known
for their ability to give chase.
Native to the southwestern United States,
and northwestern Mexico, the Gila monster
is a hard to spot desert dweller
spending 90% of its day underground.
Squat and heavyset with
a large tail and head,
they grow to be about 20 inches
long and weigh two pounds.
Their skin is studded with dorsal scales.
Black in color with scattered patterns
of orange and red hues,
they camouflage well
amongst desert pebbles and rocks.
Gila monsters prey on small
desert animals and their eggs
by using their acute sense of smell.
Once located, they bite into
their prey with their teeth
and don't let go.
They chew relentlessly
until the venom stored
in their salivary glands can
work its way into their prey.
Although quite toxic,
their bite is not fatal
to adult humans.
Sadly, the number of Gila
monsters in the wild are dropping.
They've lost their habitat to housing
and agricultural development,
but since they spend most
of their time underground,
we do not know how many are left.
This is the Gila monster.